Yes I really believe that role models are
very important for the future of the Middle
East. I believe what we need in the business
community, the economic community[inaudible]
community and the agricultural community,
and women scientists, I think we need leaders
that can demonstrate accountability and transparency
[inaudible] who can commitment themselves
to the public, who can commit themselves to
the future of their nations by investing so
much in education and creating opportunities.
As for us, we’re different because we still
have that profession; we’re different because[inaudible]
and we’re focusing all of our attention
on peace. Our piece is a piece on placing
a two step solution instead Palestine and
Israel [inaudible] to live side by side with
peace and security with the state of Israel
[inaudible]. Our role models, our young leaders
that are emerging in Palestine are missing
the product of election in every speed of
life and our Palestinian society we have elections,
democracy was not [inaudible] certain lines
have been failed but democracy works and I
believe that the opportunity is there for
this region to go ahead and stay the course
in the direction of accountability and transparency
of education. We can not talk about economic
development, prosperity, creating an environment
for and a better future for our young men
and women without education. Education is
the key. Today we stand tall as Palestinians
because we can say we have reached the level
of 99% literacy rate. Delivering that level
of literacy is really alarming and something
must be done by all leaders. To see to it
that our investment in education proceeds
any other field without differentiating between
them what [inaudible]